l'eco trail de paris l'une des courses
les plus importantes en ile de france
cette année quatorze mille personnes se
sont inscrites pour l'épreuve
la conférence de presse avait lieu au
premier étage de la tour eiffel
[Musique]
cette année les qautre elle proposera
cinq formats les distances 10 18 30 45 1
80 km au départ de lille de loisirs de
saint quentin en yvelines 80 km c'est
beaucoup c'est un parcours qui est quand
même assez exigeant on parle du domaine
de l'île lauzière de saint quentin en
yvelines avec un un territoire elle est
aidée des parcours qui passe par buqueux
versailles et et autres cette exigence
est démonté ces des descentes c'est des
changements de rythme et c'est de la
distance ont donc oui faut
l'entraînement il y aura une touche de
glamour sur cette eco trail quatre miss
france vont gravir les marches de la
tour eiffel pour l'association les
bonnes fées cette année nous avons
veille malama chavez maeva cook et marie
l'orphelin et une 4e encore qui est en
train de se motiver
franchement c'est bon enfant on le fait
vraiment pour notre association
grâce à l'argent qu'on va pouvoir
récolter cette année on va pouvoir
financer 150 et craint des faits sont
des sacs qu'on distribue dans les
maternités à des femmes dans le besoin
la course comprend également plusieurs
partenaires dont le département des
yvelines
les deux épreuves principales de sale
but 45 et du 80 km partaient des
yvelines respectivement du château de
versailles et de la base de 50 ans
en yvelines et puis aussi parce qu'il ya
les valeurs partagées avec l'eco trail
concernant le domaine du développement
durable la 13ème édition de l'eco trail
ce sera donc le 14 mars prochain départ
depuis l'île de loisirs de saint quentin
en yvelines